bring up that [ __ ] this dude's tweet was
yeah I think tinder is not for me
can you read this [ __ ] you'd be [ __ ]
with but I'm trying to tell you I'm a
grown-ass man I ain't got time to be
playing that [ __ ] Oh what okay so I
guess the story is that they met on
tinder and he said he was gonna take her
to a rave okay and she asked for him to
buy her a Jersey okay and he said no and
that was I guess is that's where this is
I don't [ __ ] with thirsty guys l'm out
so quit your assuming you should
honestly feel lucky you have a girl that
looks like me as your rave bay for the
this is like a movie we got a nick we
got a make another movie about this oh
yeah grapesy rave bay hundred-person it
gets better by the way guys a numerous
drop pasties for men coming next year
it's example petals but for your balls
yeah i gotta talk about that dog that
punched me square in the nuts dude
anyway no cockiness or none but I look a
B G is [ __ ] Haitian baby girl and you
look nothing like an a B oh my god this
is a movie this is a movie keep going
dude I look a B Jesus [ __ ] and you look
nothing like a navy be sorry
just being blunt right now no games need
to be played right now since you groan
right I can hear this [ __ ] oh yeah then
no time for games just be honest I'd
look dumb next to you lol imagine
sending [ __ ] 15 messages in a row
like this yeah you and your nutcase I'm
pretending like you don't and ending it
with lol like you don't care yeah that
cocaine I'm a bar from Twitter that
cocaine kicking her ass [ __ ] eyes just
going nuts she's like the clip was
pretty funny but that the caption is
just so funny okay kicking her ass it's
like the perfect phrase to describe like
King too hard on like adderall and [ __ ]
like that it's kicking my ass you say
that like I never been with an you say
that like a nerve build an ABG before
this is to raise do fall
I love the auto capitalization at all
and I turn that [ __ ] off man this is
like you're trying to act like you don't
care and it's like you do you act like
I've never been with an Asian baby girl
before this is the fast and furious of
rate of rave arguments and yeah I'm
still choosing to go with you
I look like those bad stuck-up [ __ ]
oh you look like one but you aren't one
you just look like what so what am i
doing dancing on you go find are they
arguing like while at the rave I have no
idea maybe they like went to the merch
table and she was like I want that
Jersey and he was like no [ __ ] and then
she was like maybe she ditched them then
and then now they're having go find
another ABG then that's cool lol I will
lol I will go ask another coffee shop
girl for show alright let mount your
loss well it's been a fun two days don't
care see it's good to see your could've
just let you could have just left it
there but you know this is a sign that
he wants us to keep going of course the
fact that he said well it's been a fun
two days yeah yet he's pushing her you
know he wants her to keep [ __ ] blown
up also if you're a BG the why are you
using o WB G as your emoji damn messed
up huh
you had a fun night but you want to be
so you could have had a fun I want to be
so hard-headed I sound blunts but damn
complimenting herself in the argument I
sound blunt as [ __ ]
um yeah I just want to take a moment
here just to say I sound pretty blunt
right now kind of sick it's not the
jersey cuz your ground right it's the
principle law not office show gonna have
a fun ass night regardless ty Lopez told
me he taught me it's not the money it's
the principle of it
the guy that I literally met at the rave
took me shopping the next day I did have
to ask why me make up all I'm asking is
a jersey like 60 bucks
oh my god dude get a job this is such
only childish job this is such only
child should get the [ __ ] out of here
it's like 60 bucks hey t max come on I
was gonna dance up on you and you can't
shell out 80 bucks you cheap it I was
gonna dance up on you with the jersey
what oh wow he's gonna wear the jersey I
would have been your ABG all night in
the Jersey for 80 bucks but you want to
be [ __ ] hard-headed yeah I gotta be
blunt as [ __ ] right now babe it's not
the 60 or 80 bucks the way is it no it's
the principle it's the principle behind
it you can't just ask me for a jersey
and expect me to [ __ ] buy you one
we're not at school where's the
principal am I like in trouble or
something I need attention oh I didn't
know we were in high school
what are you talking about the principal
I'm talking about $80 you're talking
about the who's the principal [ __ ]
dude oh my god
she had a job [ __ ] sounds like you
fumbled the bag
lol damn bro I'm gonna give him plus one
for that
I like that well that was a [ __ ] I liked
that one that was a sneak overhand right
yeah she jabbed and then the fist came
over the top she's like what big took it
right there I don't dance like all the
oh here we go here we go this is the
best part right here you ready yeah I
don't dance like these girls out here I
really don't it's different but pretty
LM out it's seductive has a girl
seductively been on you before
passionately
slow but on b-bros this save the last
dance what the [ __ ] is this man and [ __ ]
out of here wait wait a minute
passionately slow but yet still on B
that is crazy he's like how are you
doing this so passionate I'll do imagine
just just listener
imagine for one second okay an ABB or
perhaps perhaps an ABG yeah whatever
you're into whatever you're into dancing
up on you okay they're not dancing like
these other girls out here and now not
at all
okay you look down you think how are
they dancing so passionately so slowly
but yet still at 130 BPM dude I imagine
she says the BPM of whatever alidium
song is playing right now bro imagine
imagine this imagine this it's a hundred
60 bpm it's fast it's hardstyle
but somehow she can dance halftime
perfectly so it's like Burnett panic
panic but her as like but it's to the
Hat and you're just like so so you would
say it's slow but yet still um be on B I
lost count of how many times you told me
you know how to dance because it's
really something else that's how I
that's how much I'm trying to let you
know it's that different you will love
it you would want me to stop at all so
she she hasn't even danced on him
although this is hilarious something
else is like the most like boomer term
yeah she's not using it like that but
it's like this dancing is really
something else yeah I'm telling you it's
really something out of this world you
know it's not as not as not often that
you find an ABG with moxie but this girl
right here she's got moxie fellas I tell
you look at these text messages right
here exactly something else that's a
choice bit of calico I say hmm oh that's
the end oh it's not the end there's way
[ __ ] more but that's the end of the
good part you wouldn't want me to stop
at all like my dances are worth throwing
money at than be a stripper B yeah I
know for sure remember that but I can
dance better than these grown women oh
alright you know there's more to life
than being all the dance like a stripper
right ooh Travis with the [ __ ] of
course that's why I've been studying all
day for fun oh now now she's talking
about school
that's why I've been studying all day
for finals this oh [ __ ]
don't call her dumb [ __ ] bread yeah I
know I studied for my finals this
morning [ __ ]
if it's for school bet I'm studying all
out for it if it's for a bet out of
dance all out for it you know the
funniest thing about this whole thing is
is that like you know when you see to me
at least you know when you see like
girls at raves like rolling so [ __ ]
hard just staring at their phones just
typing maniacally this is in the dark
you know [ __ ] Major Lazer is playing
or some [ __ ] and their lights just on
their eyes and they're like trying to
shoot him it's this is what they're
typing bro we almost missed the best
part right here find a girl that cares a
lot for school and loves to have fun and
loves to dance seductively and ratchet
what are you looking for in a girl oh
you know man just a girl that loves
school yeah and knows how to have fun
hmm she loves to dance yeah I love those
you know things seductively though
seductive dancing okay but also ratchet
oh yeah cool yeah you know oh oh oh oh
what's this that's a whole page of grey
that's a whole page of receives messages
but not a single one sent huh the Hindu
both it is really down about it oh damn
she waited imagine all of this over 80
[ __ ] dollars yeah now I'm out I'd
have been hit block out of it the first
15 I'd have been block 9 night see
Jersey yeah it's a [ __ ] Jersey yeah
yeah turn your phone off
yeah for a walk see ya dude mmm forty
minutes later I danced on this guy and
realized he didn't even deserving me
dancing on him like that oh [ __ ] here we
go so I regret that I mean do you
deserve me dancing on you if you really
want me to be your rave BAE a you this
is [ __ ] okay
you ever send in a word rave Bay
seriously what the hell is now say
what's the magic word you said please
please stop ah there you go ha ha I'll
stop you want me to stop stop like leave
you alone alone oh my god oh my god bro
no no no no this is oxic man he had a
don't give me something that's an
elastic [ __ ] all that so I think what we
do is we make I think what we got to do
is make like a sort of like a hip-hop
song that's also sort of EDM like futsal
shuffle or whatever ready call it rave
Bay yeah yeah I think that's a good move
for us yeah we should I actually think
that's a really funny concept will you
be my rave BAE did I really have to go
the bathroom
you